de nouvelles révélations concernant
laetitia avia qui interviennent peu
après un camouflet pour la députée dont
la loi contre la haine en ligne était
retoquée par le conseil constitutionnel
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec didier maïsto président de sud
radio bonsoir didier maïsto merci d'être
avec nous à ses côtés cyril d'allemands
chercheurs associés pour l'institut
thomas more bonsoir à vous aussi
si lille d'helmand merci d'être avec
nous première question que j'ai envie de
vous poser est ce que mediapart est
clairement devenu en france dont ils
semblent de la justice et je dirais même
de la justice politique
didier maïsto bonsoir je ne crois pas
que je sais pas si mediapart est devenu
l'antichambre de la justice force est de
constater que la justice en france est
complètement grippé complètement en tant
qu'admin et dans le port est ouverte et
politiques de la république française ou
de ce qu'il en reste nous je vous
renvoie à ce qu'a dit eliane houlette
ancienne patronne du parquet national
financier même si comme il est d'usagé
en france quand on fait un certain
nombre de révélations
on revient deux jours après où lendemain
sur ses propres révélations en disant
que les français n'ont pas compris qu'on
a été mal compris ou que les français
est trop pidio scellé c'est un secret de
polichinelle la justice française n'est
pas indépendant les parquets ne sont pas
indépendants on peut observer une
sévérité absolue dans certains cas et
une lenteur extrême dans d'autres donc
mediapart comme nous le faisons à sud
radio comme je lé fais dans différents
sites le lanceur ou lyon capitale lors
je m'occupe un moment donné si vous ne
me faites pas c'est terrible d'ailleurs
de gaza du ramdam médiatique du battage
médiatique les affaires finissant
d'aimer ambre et sont complètement
enterré donc mediapart est un média de
salubrité publique parce que évidemment
malheureusement aujourd'hui la justice
est uniquement politique
voilà ce que je peux dire sur ces
sources de façon générale par rapport à
votre question
ils d'allemands sur les faits alors
laetitia vient elle dément s'est fait
ces révélations de mediapart à ce
qu'elle vous ont surprises ce genre
d'affaires finalement deviendrait-elle
assez courante en france
en fait bon soir le je pense que le
problème 99% du du problème bas par
rapport aux estampes par le modèle
existant parlementaires et les problèmes
liés à donc notamment de leur
utilisation à part les parlementaires
est liée à leur statut il n'y a pas de
statut en date de l'assistant
parlementaire et a justement comme il
n'y a pas de statut il n'y a pas de
définition de poste et il n'y a pas de
grille indiciaire de grilles de
rémunération moi j'ai été pendant la
perfusion vous parler un petit mail
pauvres sous entendu tout à l'heure
j'étais vraiment choquée par les
affirmations de certains journalistes
quand ils parlaient d'emplois fictifs
comment vous les qualifier un emploi
fictif à partir du nom n'existe pas de
définition de cet emploi ccas cadets en
est là en fait souvent il ya des
conclusions de genre qui s'opère au
niveau de l'utilisation des ressources
en matière de ressources humaines
constituent des assistants
parlementaires parce qu'un assistant
parlementaire il peut à s'occuper du
courrier il peut s'occuper d'organiser
des manifestations d'organiser des
réunions il peut s'occuper de l'agenda
mais il faut aussi à rédiger à des
questions écrites des propositions de
loi ou à des amendements donc en fait
tout dépend de tout dépend de la
définition que que le parlementaire va
donner à la fonction de son assistant
parlementaire et vous n'avez jamais ce
problème avec des assistants ou les
collaborateurs de sénateurs parce qu'ils
ont un statut donc qui dit statut dit
niveau de compétence et diddy aussi
grille indiciaire
est-ce que lier mesto du coup par
conséquent c'est vraiment ce statut des
assistants parlementaires qu'il faut
réformer puisque manifestement on l'a
déjà vu effectivement avec la sphère
fillon il ya et un flou dans ce domaine
oui c'est un flou si également l'a très
bien dit je bois qui connaît bien la
question c'est un flou savamment et
sciemment entretenu parce qu'en fait ce
sont des contrats
droit privé avec de l'argent public avec
un contrat de confiance qui est
uniquement qui est unilatéral en fait un
le député moi j'ai fait ce boulot aussi
peu le rompre à tout moment et donc vous
êtes un petit peu je vais pas employer
les grands mots mais l'esclave du du
député vous détendre dès décembre
vouloir et allez soyons magnanimes 90%
des parts le des députés utilisent leurs
récits de leurs assistants
parlementaires pour ce pour leur bon
vouloir coller des affiches faire les
campagnes électorales municipales et 10
amendement rédigé des discours de telle
sorte que souvent les députés paraissent
le barbier le mercredi lors des
questions d'actualité mais dans la soute
il y a les assistants parlementaires qui
font tout le boulot est entré dans une
hypocrisie générale parce que les gens
ne connaissent pas le sujet on dit on
l'a vu à l'occasion de la fiac fillon
ont dit c'est un emploi fictif
mais je suis d'accord avec ce que vient
de dire si vilain emplois fictifs encore
faut-il pour pour délivrer gérer de dire
le la secte à sion d'emplois fictifs
encore faut-il définir ce qu'est
l'emploi quelle est sa grille indiciaire
quels sont les tenants et les
aboutissants quelles sont les fonctions
quelles sont les missions
or c'est le flou absolu et donc tout le
monde se retranche derrière cette
hypocrisie
comment voulez vous démontrer la réalité
d'un emploi si cet emploi n'est pas
défini et c'est bien tout le problème
quant à madame alia en fait on va y
venir
il ya eu un camouflé comme vous l'avait
indiqué dans votre titre est dans votre
accroche sur sa loi et j'observe peu
quand même
nous étions très très peu dans les
médias a donné un petit peu de la voix
il faut que ce soit neuf sages qui
rappelle ce qu'est notre constitution
j'avais imaginé que l'ensemble des
médias
fût ce un petit peu complètement révolté
par cette loi liberticide
il était de bon ton simplement de en et
sans faire du juridisme de ce couple de
se référer à la constitution pour dire
que cette loi était h
portable quoique madama vient aurait
plutôt besoin d'une bonne psychanalyse
elle a dû souffrir de brimades dans sa
vie passée elle a voulu en faire une loi
générale qui a été censuré parce qu'en
france il ya une constitution il ya des
lois il ya des lois fondamentales et
morsures en tout cas c'est pas remise en
cause et ça vient parce qu'elle se dit
effectivement déçu par par cet accueil
un de sa loi mais ne repense pas elle le
dit dans un tweet du 18 juin notre
détermination à lutter contre les
discours de haine reste entière nous le
devons à toutes les victimes de l'aisne
en ligne on a un petit peu be sur gay
effectivement du débat initial cyril
d'helmand la raison de s'accrocher
effectivement 7 à cette loi des tice et
avia pour moi pas totalement tort en
fait le flanc le fond du problème c'est
que la haine en ligne les com comment
voulez-vous juridique à riddes et
infantino
c'est complètement aberrant fait
intellectuellement le sentiment de
propos manifestement et nous va dépendre
de l'interprétation de celui qui va le
lire vous pouvez pas et judiciariser ce
sentiment s'est laissé ses adhérents
après on peut voit là comme dans le
meilleur des mondes deux triplés on peut
pénaliser pourquoi pas l'amour
l'empathie tout tout tout tout sentiment
en fait c'était un pas de trop mais qui
à mon avis vient quand même qui vient de
loin en fait depuis des années la fin
des années 80 et au début des années 90
on à alan grignotage des libertés
fondamentales
à des libertés publiques et aura
fondamentaux pour pour être précis avec
une surenchère de lois sécuritaires dont
il n'y a pas vraiment en fait d'étude
d'impact d'ailleurs sur quelles sont les
conséquences de cette multiplication de
lois sécuritaires sur la délinquance
il ya quasiment aucune preuve qu'elle
que l'impact soit réelle et là on est
sûr sur un point de bascule en fait et
d'ailleurs qui est assez assez étrange
mais qu'en sortir de de confinement avec
une atteinte quand même très très lourde
à une liberté fondamentale qui est la
liberté simplement d'aller et venir
les deux projets majeurs du gouvernement
ont été justement la loi bien et le
projet stop qu'ovide dont la
intrinsèquement pose un problème quant
aux ventes à la liberté d'expression et
liberté de communication comme la
commune a très très bien a souligné le
conseil constitutionnel et l'autre porte
atteinte intrinsèquement à la vie privée
et éventuellement s'il devait devenir
obligatoire en cas de nouvelles
pandémies également à la liberté d'aller
et venir
donc moi je pense qu'elle a tort de
s'acharner
je pense que les sages ont été
d'ailleurs très précis et dont ils ont
même donné pour ainsi dire une petite
leçon de démocratie à l'assemblée en en
indiquant que le législateur à des
porter atteinte à la liberté
d'expression et de communication
une attaque qui n'était pas adapté
nécessaires et proportionnées
alors le mauvais sens avec didier maïsto
en cdi salvia est candidate aux
élections le rappel dans le 12e
arrondissement de paris ces révélations
de mediapart arrive avec ce calendrier
est effectivement intéressant à six
jours du scrutin quelles pourraient en
être les conséquences à ce que selon
vous les français sanctionneront la dea
pour la députée pour cela de toute façon
vous avez vu qu'avec sud radio
nous avons fait un certain nombre de
sondages il semble avéré même si une
élection n'est jamais joué d'avancé que
madame hidalgo gagnera il aurait été un
petit peu je sais pas élégant de la part
de madame avia 2
de reconnaître que elle se situe est
elle même dans un état de droit et que
le conseil constitutionnel avait tranché
et elle continue malheureusement ne pas
être à la hauteur et de faire part de
son humeur et de son sentiment or quel
est le cas les l'apanage je dirais et
les avantages d'un état de droit c'est
de justement par ledroit transcender
tous les sentiments individuels par la
constitution et le droit c'est la forme
la plus évoluée du vivre ensemble et je
crois que madame avia ne l'a pas compris
elle a dû sans doute souffrir de
brimades et de vexations dans sa vie
personnelle elle ses assistants
parlementaires emporté plein de campagne
on verra à ce pays la justice ils ont
accusé d'homophobie de racisme et de
mots très très dur et on voit qu'elle
est un petit peu à la du mal à percer le
plafond de verre et qu'elle essaie de
faire de son cas particulier un cas
général et les sages du conseil
constitutionnel ont rappelé à bon
escient que la france demeurait un état
de droit où l'arbitraire ou et et le
sentiment personnel n'avaient pas leur
place
merci didier mesto merci à cyril
d'allemands d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france